[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS'
WORLD," I'M JESSE WATTERS.
THE JIG IS UP FOR JOE BIDEN  *
HIS CREDIBILITY IS SHOT WITH
CHRIS HELPED BUILT AT 43%.
IN AFGHANISTAN JOE LEFT
AMERICANS BEHIND.
HE'S COVERING THIS UP, THE WHOLE
HOSTAGE CRISIS.
STILL TAKING ORDERS FROM THE
TALL BADGE.
THE COMMANDER IN CHEECH
LAUNCHING A HIDEOUS DRONE STRIKE
THAT KILLED KIDS INSTEAD OF
TERRORISTS.
INFLATION IS WIPING OUT OUR WAGE
GAINS.
THE RECOVERY IS WEAK AND BIDEN
HASN'T CRUSHED COVID.
HE PROMISED TO UNITE US BUT HIS
MANDATES ARE DIVIDING US.
OPEC TOLD JOE TO TAKE A HIKE
WHEN HE ASKED THEM TO PUMP MORE
OIL.
EVEN NOW THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
ADMITTING THERE IS AS PROBLEM.
>> IT'S BEEN A TOUGH WEEK FOR
JOB.
PROFESSOR.
>> ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS SHOWEDE
EXACT OPPOSITE.
>> WHAT HE HAS DONE SO FAR
HASN'T REALLY WORKED.
JESSE: THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER
WORSE THAN EVER BEFORE AND BIDEN
IS BLAMING A BROKEN SYSTEM.
YES, HE BROKE IT.
NO WALL, NO REMAIN IN MEXICO,
JUST LET EVERYBODY IN.
THE DEL RIO BRIDGE IN TEXAS
FILLED WITH THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
HAITIANS, THIRD WORLD CONDITIONS
SLEEPING IN DIRT IN 100 DEGREE
WEATHER.
SUFFERING BABIES.
HE LET THOUSANDS OF HAITIANS
INTO AMERICA, SENDING SOME BACK
TO HAITI, SOME FIGHTING I.C.E.
OFFICERS ON THEIR WAY HOME.
THE CLAIM THAT BORDER PATROL
AGENTS WERE WHIPPING HAITIANS.
THE STORY WAS DEBUNKED IN HOURS.
THOSE WERE THE HORSES' REINS.
MAXINE WATERS SAID THIS WAS
WORSE THAN SLAVERY.
>> WHAT THE HELL ARE WE DOING
HERE?
WHAT WE WITNESSED TAKES US BACK
HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
WHAT WE WITNESSED IS WORSE THAN
WHAT WE WITNESSED WITH SLAVERY.
COWBOYS THEIR REINS WHIPPING
BLACK PEOPLE.
JESSE: AL SHARPTON GOT IN ON THE
RACE HUSTLE.
FLEW DOWN TO TEXAS AND SCREAMED
ABOUT SLAVERY.
>> NO ONE WANTS TO HEAR YOUR
RACIST DOCTRINE IN DELL WE OH.
>> YOU ARE A RACIST.
NOBODY WANTS YOU IN TEXAS.
WHY ARE YOU NOT A VOICE FOR THE
CHILDREN?
JESSE: EVEN THE PHOTOGRAPHER WHO
TOOK THE PHOTO SAID IT WAS A
LIE.
HE SAID I NEVER HAVE SEEN THEM
WHIP ANYTHING WITH THE THING.
HE WAS SWINGING IT.
THAT CAN BE EASILY MISCONSTRUED
WHEN USUAL LOOKING AT THE
PICTURE.
THAT'S THE POINT.
THE LEFT WANTS TO DISTRACT WITH
A FAKE CRISIS TO DISTRACT FROM
THE REAL CRISIS THEY CREATED.
SO THEY PUT THE AGENTS ON DESK
DUTY AND LAUNCH AN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE STUPID HOAX.
A FORMER BORDER PATROL HORSE
COORDINATOR SAID IT WILL BE HARD
FOR THEM TO DO THEIR JOB NOW.
>> THE HORSE IS A GREAT TOOL WE
USED FOR ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS.
WHEN THAT'S GONE, IT WILL BE
HARDER TO CONTROL THE AREA.
WE DON'T HAVE WHIPS, WE DON'T
CARRY WHIPS, AND THEY WEREN'T
WHIPPING THEM.
IT WAS A FORM OF PRESS AND
RELEASE.
WITH THE TWIRLING THE REINS WAS
JUST ANOTHER TOOL THEY USE TO
GET THE HORSES TO DO WHAT THEY
ASK THEM.
JESSE: JOE BIDEN PRETENDED TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
WHOLE BORDER MESS.
BUT THEN PASSED THE BUCK.
>> DO YOU TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE CHAOS UNFOLDING?
>> OF COURSE I TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY, I'M PRESIDENT.
BUT THAT WAS MORIBLE TO SEE
PEOPLE TREATED LIKE THEY DID
HORSES BARELY RUNNING OVER
PEOPLE WHILE BEING STRAPPED.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND I PROMISE
YOU THOSE PEOPLE WILL PAY.
JESSE: HE'S EITHER LYING OR HIS
HANDLERS DON'T TELL HIM THE
FACTS.
THIS IS STRAIGHT-UP
ANTI-AMERICAN.
THE PRESIDENT'S WORDS AND
ACTIONS ARE DESPICABLE AND HE
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF HIMSELF.
HIS BUDDY CHUCK SCHUMER SAYS WE
NEED TO KEEP THE BORDERS OPEN
BECAUSE WE NEED CHEAP LABOR.
>> WE ARE SHORT OF WORKERS
BECAUSE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
DRAMATICALLY CUT BACK ONLY
IMMIGRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE NEED THEM OUR LABOR FORCE.
JESSE: BIDEN CREATED A LABOR
SHORTAGE BY HANDING OUT
PREMONEY.
THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRAT DONORS
WANTED.
BECAUSE IT TURNS TEXAS BLUE.
JOE BIDEN WAS WARNED ABOUT THE
CRISIS AT THE BORDER AND DID
NOTHING.
BORDER PATROL EMAILS FROM JUNE
SHOWS AGENTS PREDICTED THIS
SURGE AND WERE BEGGING FOR HELP.
BUT JOE BIDEN IGNORED IT.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T WANT ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THIS.
HE HASN'T BEEN TO THE BORDER
NOW, OR MAYBE NEVER.
>> HAS BEEN * EVER BEEN TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> I WILL HAVE TO LOOK BACK IN
MY HISTORY BOOKS AND CHECK THE
TIMES HE HAS BEEN TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AND WE
CAN'T FIND ANY RECORD OF HIM
VISITING THE BORDER.
WHEN THERE ARE DISASTERS IN THIS
COUNTRY LIKE A WILDFIRE OR
HURRICANES PRESIDENTS GO TO SEE
FOR THEMSELVES FIRSTHAND WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY SO HE CAN HAVE
INFORMED POB TO MAKE POLICY.
JESSE: JOE IS NOT FIGHTING FOR
US.
HE'S SWAMPED BY PROBLEMS HE
CREATED.
THIS IS A FAILE